in this video i want to expose you to a
special class of mirrors called
parabolic
mirrors or sometimes called parabolic
parabolic reflectors and what's neat
about parabolic mirrors and i'll draw a
cross section of one right here and if
you're familiar with the algebra they
are essentially the cross section the
cross section especially is in the shape
of a parabola so let me draw a parabolic
mirror right here so it's in the shape
of a parabola just like that and what's
neat about a parabolic mirror and i'm
not going to go into the math right here
i just want to give you the general idea
is if and let me just draw its principal
axis so this is kind of the line of
symmetry of the parabola
so this is its principal axis
right over here it divides it into and
in a parabolic this is just a cross
section you could imagine if this was
spun around if it was spun around that
principle axis you would get something
that would look like this you would get
something that
would look like a bowl
it looks like a bowl
but it's actually the shape of a
parabola it's not it's not an actual a
sphere shape so if you rotate this
around you would get a circle around the
edge so this would be a circle right
over here but this shape this shape down
here is not a hemisphere it's not
spherical it's actually a parabola and
the reason why we care about a parabola
or what's neat about parabolic mirrors
is if i have
parallel light rays coming into a
parabolic mirror
so if i have
do my best to draw power a parallel
light ray so parallel to its
central axis so if i have a light ray
that comes like that it will reflect off
of the parrot so it's parallel to this
principle axis it will reflect
like that now if i and i'm i'll tell you
what's neat about this in a second let
me draw another parallel ray let's say i
have a parallel ray that's coming in
that's coming in right over there so it
hits the parabolic miller at that point
mirror at that point it's going to
reflect so it comes in like that and if
i have another array
that comes in like this that comes in
like this it will reflect so that the
reflection goes right over there so
what's neat about this what's neat is
any light ray that comes in parallel any
incident light ray that's parallel to
the principal axis of this parallel
black miller mirror the reflected ray is
going to go through the same point i
don't care where you hit the mirror as
long as it was parallel to the principal
axis the reflected ray is going to hit
this point
and this point right here is the focus
this right there is the focus
this is the focus of the parabolic
mirror now what's what's neat about this
well let's say that you are trying to
capture heat from the sun you're trying
to
concentrate the the the electromagnetic
radiation from the sun so what you could
imagine you could go to the middle of
the desert
you could go to the middle of the desert
and people do do this and you set up
parabolic mirrors like this that are
pointed at the sun
and the sun's rays come in and the sun
is so far away they're essentially just
coming in parallel
because they're i mean they're they are
radiating from the sun but the sun is 93
million miles away so the rays for our
purposes are essentially coming in
parallel and what's neat about them is
is when they hit the surface of the
parabolic miller mirror
they all get they all get reflected to
one point so if you have a ray coming in
there it's going to get reflected there
a ray coming in like that's going to get
reflected like that and so all of the
energy
all of the energy can be focused on a
point like that and so you could imagine
you might have a water pipe kind of
running into the screen here and so all
of that light energy would be used to
heat up that water pipe so it's a pretty
a neat way to concentrate energy another
thing you might want maybe instead of
taking in energy
maybe you want to give out energy so
that all of the beams of light are
parallel for example
let's say you have a light for a car if
you have a light you could imagine if
car if car headlights were just you know
if i drew a car like this let me scroll
down a little bit
if i drew a car like this let me draw
have a reasonable attempt at a car so
let's say that this is a car right over
here
i think you get the idea this is the
wheel housing that's the wheel
so forth and so on this isn't about the
drawing of the car but you can imagine
if we just stuck
light bulbs
at the front of cars
so you could imagine just a light bulb
sitting at the front of a car
so that's a light bulb
and that would provide light but it
would provide light in all directions
radially outward it would be kind of
useless first of all it would probably
the way i drew it here would probably
show up in the dude's eye who's trying
to drive the car but it's a lot of
wasted energy a lot of the light is
coming back onto the car and it's
pointing in all sorts of random
directions it's not so useful when you
are driving a car you want all of the
light pointed at the road or maybe the
stuff that's directly above the road so
how could you point the light well you
could use a parabolic mirror and all of
your any car you look at will have a
light inside of a parabolic mirror and
what does that do
let's say i put let's say instead of
this
instead of this situation that i just
drew let me clear this out and i'll draw
it on a larger scale just to make it
let's say i had a parabolic mirror here
so i have a powerblock miller a mirror
obviously this looks more like a snow
shovel or something but i'm drawing it
way huge just so you get the general
idea so this is a parabolic mirror and
let's say we put the light bulb now we
put the light bulb at the focal point
at the focus
at the focus of this parabolic mirror
now what's going to happen well light
that has to go in this direction that
comes readily outward that's good
because that's light that's being useful
to the driver it's actually illuminating
the road
but light that's going backwards light
that's radiating outward from that focus
of the parabola it's going to be
reflected it's going to do the exact
opposite of that solar energy collector
it's going to be reflected out parallely
or in a parallel way it's just going to
so all of the light because of this
because of this parabolic reflector or
parabolic mirror all of the light that
this light source is generating or most
of it is going to be emitted parallel
parallel to the principal axis of the
problem actually you could point the
light if you actually moved this
parabola around you can point which
direction the light's in so it's
actually a pretty a pretty useful thing
to have
now the other thing about parabolic
mirrors is that they actually form real
images in the last video we talked about
the notion of a virtual image you think
something is there because it looks like
the light is converging at some point
but that point isn't even there it's
actually from some other point it's
getting reflected but a real image
let me draw it over here so let me draw
a parabolic mirror
let me draw big parabolic mirrors to
make the diagram clear
and let me draw its principal axis
so its principal axis this is kind of a
side profile of it
this is let me draw its principal axis
just like
just
like that and let's put an object so let
me i'm going to define a couple of
interesting points here so that first of
all we have our focal point
i'll call that f
and then there's something called the
center of curvature and the curvature i
always imagine is a sphere but for
center of curvature of a parabolic
mirror it's actually going to be two
times the focal length so this distance
right here
so this distance right here let me make
it clear i'll call that
this distance right here
is f
then this distance right here to the
center of curvature we should call that
point c but this distance over here is
going to be f as well or it's going to
be 2f from you could imagine that vertex
or that kind of mac that minimum point
of the parabola depending on how you
want to view it
now what i want to do is put a couple of
objects in front of this parabolic
mirror and just think about what happens
to the light rays of that object so
let's first
let's first put an object here so i'm
just going to draw the object as an
arrow
so i just draw the object as an arrow
and that object you know maybe some
light is shining on it from who knows
what direction but it's going to reflect
that light diffusely assuming it's not
shiny and i'm just going to pick a point
on this object to radially
emit light outward from or reflect light
outward from and see what happens to
those light rays
so let's say and for the for the sake of
simplicity whenever you do something
with a parabolic mirror it's good to
emit one radial ray that's parallel and
one that goes through the focus because
we know what they're going to do after
that so let's do one that's parallel so
and of course these are just two of the
gazillions of light rays that are being
emitted from every point of this object
but we're just doing this to understand
what will the image of this object
actually look like so let's do one
parallel
it hits the surface of the parabolic
mirror and then it reflects and goes
through the focus
we know that already
and then let's make another light ray go
through the focus
so let's make another light ray go
through let me draw it a little bit
better than that another light ray going
through the focal point just like that
and then it reflects and it'll be
reflected in a parallel way
so what just happened here those two
rays that were emitted by the same point
those two rays that were emitted by the
same point on this arrow object they
both get you know they they radially
emit outward they reflect on this
parabolic mirror at two different points
but then they converge again
they converge right over there
and actually if you put and we could do
that with every point if you did the the
stuff that leaves that point actually
both of those are going to go and come
back go through the focal point and then
come back right over here i mean they'll
keep going but you can imagine you can
do this with every point every point on
this arrow and what you're going to do
is get an image that looks like this
you're going to have an image that looks
like this
this point up here corresponds to that
point this point corresponds to that
point and so if you were to put
if you were to put a screen if you were
to put a screen right over here
if you were to put this is a screen
a screen it could just be a i don't know
a white tablecloth or if there was a
wall right over here
then it would actually show the image
you would actually be projecting the
image onto this wall right over here it
was act it would actually be a projected
image and that projected image that
we're talking about where the light is
converging so the light comes radially
outward from each point of this arrow
and then it converges on a point on the
screen that can that image that gets
formed we call that a real image it's
real image this is a real
real image and you might want to compare
that to what we called a virtual image a
virtual image is an image that looks
like it's coming from some place because
it looks like things are diverging from
some point but that that it's they've
really been reflected off of some
surface so what we think is there really
isn't there a real image is an image
that's actually projectable we could put
a screen right over here and then these
guys are going to be hitting the screen
and essentially diffusing the exact same
light they will be diffusing the exact
same light as this point of the actual
object
of the actual object and because of that
the screen will look just like the
object this is a projectable image
anyway hopefully you found that useful i
realize i've gone longer than i like to
at some of these videos we'll talk a
little bit more about parabolic mirrors
in the next video